good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so
health on your journey
today's message is have a high pain
threshold over you Ilan I push one
wanders happy focused on the short-term
and money coming in when creating
company because otherwise the company
will for die so that the I think that a
lot of times people think like creating
company is going to be fun I would say
it's not it's really not that fun when
their periods of fun and their periods
of where to where to store for and
particularly if you CEO of a company you
actually have a distillation of all the
worst problems in a company there's no
point in spending your time on things
that are going right so you only spend
on things on your time on things that
are going wrong and there are things
that are going wrong that other people
can't can't take care of so you like the
worst you have a filter for the crappers
problems in the company the most
pernicious and painful problems so I
wouldn't say it's I think you have to
feel quite compelled to do it and have a
fairly high pain threshold and there's a
friend of mine who says like starting
companies like staring at the abyss and
eating glass and there's some truth to
that we're staring into your best part
is that you're going to be constantly
facing the extermination of the company
because most most startups fail now it's
like 90 percent ugly 99% of Starks fail
so I so you that that's the staring in
to give this part your constant
constantly saying okay if I don't get
this right the company will die should
be quite right for quite stressful and
and then eating glass part is you've got
you've got to do you've got to do the
problems you just thought you going to
work in the problems that the company
needs
work on that phone she want to work on
and so that but but you're not working
on problems that that you'd really wish
you weren't working on and so that's the
eating glass part then that goes on for
a long time so how do you keep your
focus on the big picture when you're
constantly faced with we could be out of
business in a month well it's just a
very small percentage of mental energies
on the on the big picture like you know
you know where you generally heading for
and and the factual path is going to be
some sort of zigzagging thing in that
direction and try not to deviate too far
from the path that that you want to be
on but you're going to have to do that
some degree but I don't want to I don't
to diminish the I mean I think the
product the profit motive is it is a is
a good one if the rules of an industry
are properly set up so there's only
fundamentally wrong with profit in fact
profit just means that people are paying
you more for whatever you're doing then
you're spending to create it that's a
good thing if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so
peanuts are stuck a good chunk of the
time we have to deal with a lot of crap
being an entrepreneur especially as we
are trying to build this amazing thing
that's never been done before and that's
the point your training is something
that people have not done before right
we're trying to build something special
if you're just doing the same thing as
everybody else you're going to get less
than average results because they've
been doing it longer than you have more
track record more experience and so you
want to be do something different and
doing something different comes with a
lot of pain comes with a lot of phases
comes with a lot of people judging you
or telling you that you can't do it
comes with a lot of depth on will be
self-doubt as well and then just build
up and you get a team you're going to
have to deal with everybody else's crap
you know I don't want to make this seem
like as negative situation because I
love and that's part of what you need to
do as an entrepreneur is love the crap
love the pain right if you are
super sensitive to any kind of pain any
kind of discomfort really hard to have
also successes in entrepreneur when I
recommend you doing is slowly increasing
your tolerance just like anything else
just like you know if you are trying to
learn the warning you can only do a
certain amount and then you fall and
your muscles will get tired pertain to
it just like when you start lifting
weights you can lift 10 pounds and then
20 pounds and 30 pounds you know as you
get to repetitions in your muscles grow
stronger and you can deal with more more
more MORE
so you need to learn as an entrepreneur
so one of the greatest exercises I think
you can do is actually start to hire so
many part-time with routine I think a
lot of entrepreneurs have the wrong know
being around hires we think we're giving
on somewhere team where grasses workout
debates that we're doing with them
taking away all of our pain and we're
going to be the focus of the things that
we love and that's partially true you
want to hire somebody to delegate the
stuff you don't enjoy doing as a I'm
really good at but there's still a lot
of did you didn't he would be you didn't
was there back into their issues their
motivations their struggles and all the
crap always comes back to you that you
have to doing because chunking time is
dealing with everybody else's problems
right and helping them and liking it and
want to see them grow if you're trying
to operate your business as I'm going to
build up a team of people to help you do
something amazing but I'm not going to
be the leader romantic you're talking
really care that much about the people
emergency would be on their own you're
not really going to build a big
organization and so you need to learn
how to manage and you need to learn it's
super super super super important and
better to do it on a part-time basis so
the first person I hired was for one
hour a day when I read it that was it
and not sweet out more than one out of
five times is he was bed rest even had a
job in Iowa it walked and doing other
things but it is a head to care for him
until to ask them how he was doing to
build understand his bold the other a
favor his struggles work religion
beliefs were right that's your job as
leaders to build the people up in your
organization to do amazing things to
join you on this crazy
a journey that you're on this what you
have to do and so it started appeared
you guys if you don't have anybody on
the team look to hire somebody perfect
one hour days a couple hours a week
whatever it is to free up some of your
workload but also get you used to
managing people and dealing with their
issues the more you can build up muscle
out is with the crap muscle the stronger
gets the more crap you'll be able to
deal with and the higher your green
specials will be you can build something
so the question may today is I'm curious
what's the most painful thing that
you've ever had to do any more business
so here's to find out leave it on the
comments below
looking forward see what you guys have
today I want to give a quick sure to
ain't wanna flirt for know it's one
thing into so much your figure if a copy
of my book here one word
taking that selfie with the book and
posting to Twitter as well I really
appreciate this department and I hope
you enjoy the read so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you so
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you get far more a for
another shot of espresso the Eagles
- this pain barrier experiencing pain in
your muscles and aching and just think
oh on and go on and gone and just last 2
or 3 or 4 repetitions that's what makes
actually the muscle then grow and it
divides in one from a champion and one
from not being a champion if you can't
go through this pain barrier you make it
to be a champion
if you can't go through forget it and
that's the most people like isn't this
having the guts to cut to go in and just
say I go through and I don't care what
happens you know it aches and if I fall
down I have no fear of fainting in a gym
because I know it could happen I threw
up many times while I was working out
but it doesn't matter because it's all
worth it have you ever watched a James
Bond movie where it doesn't like you
losing at some point and anyway
or Batman or Iron Man or any superhero
there has to be some diversity for you
to you know overcome to win it can't be
a champ unless you are you know in a
place where you look like you're going
to lose and then you win
the pain that's going to come with being
independent you have to embrace it
because it's going to happen and also
know that the more successful you get
the more problems you're going to have
the more not you're going to have an
entire being a boss does not mean smooth
sailing it means having the ability to
care about other people before yourself
and to untie problems on time not that's
all it is it's not business if there's
not problem there's nothing good without
struggle it just doesn't happen and all
my experiences there have been one thing
that's been successful without me
feeling some pain before it was
successful so now when there is pain I
embrace it you know I've been embracing
it I Maji about it because I know that
must mean that if I'm cool man you know
with a way to me like the darkest before
the dawn I don't want it like sound
corny but that's really what that's what
has to happen pain is a beautiful thing
Challenge is what life is about a life
without challenge of life without pain
is a life without growth and where there
is no growth they're stale stagnant
energy and that's where most people live
because most people's lives are designed
around treading a path that is void of
challenge the minute they recognize
challenge or pain they move the other
way this is a primal instinct and
normally natural but a weak perspective
most people are bored if you ask them
what do you think about your life
the same-old same-old every single day
what it was the thing same day same
different day things of this nature
that's because they're living their
lives in a lie that is shrouded in
comfort it doesn't exist they're not
challenged they're not growing they're
bored and they're better off dead
your aliveness is found in your pain
embrace it love it and grow from it